let's just jump right into uh your
investing philosophy we'll start there
first uh you basically invest in things
that everyone thinks is super weird
right now but hopefully won't think it's
weird in the future explain this
so
uh i'm the founder and managing director
of boost vc which is the accelerator for
sci-fi
our mission
is to accelerate the sci-fi future
uh and what that really what that really
means is we focus primarily on
cryptocurrency virtual reality and
aerospace and but the reason behind that
is
we invest in
ecosystems that inspire the spirit like
that they are the artists that are going
to create the future and that's what
boost vc represents all right
an example of this is you were a seed
investor in coinbase uh way before
anyone thought this was a real industry
or real thing et cetera let's use that
as an example of how you like manifest
perfect actually uh apply it
so we were boost vc we were the first
fund to ever focus on bitcoin but even
before that
i uh met this founder named brian
armstrong at uh
at a coffee shop i always give credit to
the coffee shop because i've done so
well at the coffee shop coffee shop is
called red rock uh
and i we should launch one in florida
when i come and visit uh we'll we'll
launch a red rock coffee um
and the uh
uh and i mean i mean i meet this founder
and you know
he
he goes
essentially his first line goes at some
point the world's going to be on one
financial infrastructure and this was 10
years ago 12 years ago like this was
that it's hard to grasp that now in the
crypto ecosystem because people believe
bitcoin has such a truth in the real
world but
before this is the first guy and i had
never heard of bitcoin and his name was
brian armstrong he was he founded this
company coinbase and he he goes i'm
going to build the gateway to that
financial infrastructure i believe
that bitcoin
is is that financial infrastructure and
at the time there's only bitcoin it was
just bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin um but into
some it's still bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
uh and the and so
this is this is a guy i also have this
saying where it's rational people doing
irrational things this is a guy who left
airbnb
to found a startup
in bitcoin uh airbnb
market cap at the time
was worth more than the entire
market size of bitcoin bitcoin was worth
100 million dollars total at that moment
and so he so he is that he
what bitcoin and these technologies do
is they inspire from within
the spirit and they it it becomes a
piece of your identity and this guy
uh had the audacity
to say
yeah i'm going to change the entire
financial ecosystem i'm going to change
the way that money works and i'm gonna
allow everyone equal access to the
financial system through bitcoin this
peer-to-peer distributed ledger and i i
first of you know i don't say i didn't
say yes right then i did some diligence
because
the idea sounded pretty crazy but he was
so
captivated and inspired that you had you
had to be like this
this guy he's either like insane right
like those are the people you're looking
at either insane or
or he he sees something that we don't
and so i dug in and every single person
i met in the bitcoin ecosystem was the
most dynamic inspired
spirit and so from from that basically
from then on like that's been the the
nature of the investment philosophy of
boost bc um i also here i want to tell
my whole coinbase story because
technically the decision uh
was made
on on the toilet
and
and so uh the
so technically if we were being
technical about it i had met brian and
i'd been sitting on it for about a month
by the way probably the least popular
deal at uh that was it was at a y
combinator demo day at the time um
no one like very few people have
committed uh actually i think no one
other than the start fund which you get
had committed at that point when i
talked to them and uh and he was trying
to raise a million dollars he never did
he raised six hundred thousand dollars
at the end of his cdc round um but i
i was i i talked to all these people i'd
done my diligence i emailed people i
called people and then you know it got
to the point where it was sort of like
dragging on a little bit and i was i was
i was sitting
i was doing my thinking
on the toilet
uh and that i was reading this magazine
that was right next to to me that had
been there for two years uh
year year and a half economist magazine
i read through it a thousand times
but this time i read through it and
there's an article right at the top and
it says bitcoin bubble or uh i forget
the exact title but something like that
bit burst bitcoin bubble burst and it
talks about the price of bitcoin going
up to 30
and then dropping down to zero basically
and
i was reading this and i was like
you know some people might have read
that and been like i shouldn't do this
deal bitcoin's dead i was thinking the
price of bitcoin today this was written
a year ago the price of bitcoin today is
is ten dollars twelve dollars uh
i'm in and so i call brian right there
uh well i'm i'm probably still on the
toilet at that point and i i call brian
and i tell him this whole story he
doesn't care about any of the story of
me being on the toilet he cares that i'm
in and that was uh that's that and it's
the probably the most career defining
investment i've ever made because i got
to be
i had a front row seat to the emergence
of one of the most impactful technology
communities that the world has ever seen
um which throw you know
fast forward a couple years and we got
we have pomp who
i'm
so thankful for i think uh what you have
done for the ecosystem people don't
thank you enough for and i just wanted
to show my gratitude for how much how
consistent how much
like promotion how much excitement you
send the entire ecosystem so thank you
for that i i appreciate you when you
stroke the check to coinbase do you
think it's a multi-billion dollar
company or are you like i hope i get my
money back
uh so so
i will also give brian so much credit uh
the ceo of the brian the ceo and he was
a solo founder at the time and the only
advice i kept reiterating in the room
was
uh get a co-founder like that was the
that was my main piece of advice um and
it was very kind he recently sent me a
video for my birthday that was uh saying
hey i still remember the advice you gave
and it was a good idea uh the
uh
what brian did in that meeting was he
said something that i'd never heard any
founders say
ever
which was
this could be a trillion dollar market
and i never heard trillion dollars
in any pitch meeting and i wasn't crazy
experienced at that time to be fair like
i was 26 27. um
but but i was i was in this pitch
meeting and someone says a trillion
dollars
you
you you think they're either crazy or
they're on to something and so we so i
went uh i mean i'm so glad that i ended
up saying yes i'm so glad uh that i
ended up getting this front row seat and
yeah i mean you know financially it's a
huge win for me
it wasn't bad
do you want to see how much money you
guys made off of it
are you allowed to say that uh no well
i'm allowed i mean you know if you don't
want to okay i'm reporting to myself but
no i i i won't uh it would have equated
to
uh
5000 x something like that so he made
5000 x on the coinbase investment i mean
yeah it's not 10 000 but it's pretty
good and i only and i only i only got
2500 acts on bitcoin so like you know
that's pretty cool yeah
so you made 5000 x on coinbase 2500x on
bitcoin
yeah like crazy
beginner's luck right yeah hey listen
take it how you get it whatever let's
rock and roll next next time you have a
crazy idea call me
i will
what's up guys bang bang your boy pomp
thanks so much for watching the best
business show our goal is to make this
the largest most actionable business
show in the world and to do that we need
your help we've partnered with sofi as
our exclusive sponsor because they have
a piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com pomp
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer
second is if you go on and you buy one
of the cryptocurrencies that they offer
they'll go ahead and they'll give you
ten dollars of bitcoin for free and
third some of you are saying i already
have a brokerage account i already have
an account somewhere else right now you
can get up to five thousand dollars for
transferring your account that's right
so far doesn't care where your current
account is but if you transfer it from
that place to sofi they'll pay you up to
five thousand dollars for doing it why
wouldn't you do it it's up to five
thousand dollars for free head on over
to sofi.com today to get started and
come back tomorrow and watch more of the
best business show together we're gonna
build the biggest show in the world
[Music]
you